question guys which number is considered  as the biggest number in the world the  answer is googleplex this number is  represented as 10 raised to google where  10 is the number and google is the  verbal form of the exponential number 10  raise to 100. well one thing is for sure  google plex's parents must not be happy  with them because clearly he has a lot  of zeros anyway this number is so  awfully large that it exists only in  theory and has never been used in  practical calculations even once  basically this number is the great khali  of all numbers it is so used that no one  wants to mess with it by the way no  prizes for guessing this but can you  guess the company that has named itself  taking inspiration from the word of  google let us know in the comment  section below